Richard Sherman back here on the show
how you doing Richard I'm doing
fantastic have you been I have been
great so uh what's your what's going on
with the family let's start with that
first with your family oh good
you know the wife's doing great I got a
you know three-year-old girl four year
old boy they're you know they're in
school now so they're the wife's
enjoying a little bit of a break during
the day okay so that's that's great you
know they're learning a lot coming
coming home with new words new
adventures
so what shows are on the Sherman
household what TV shows puppy pals Peppa
Pig
backyard Ian door to Explorer you know
any any any number of those shows could
be on the TV well Richard and given to
us Richard I don't want to flex here but
I will there was a recent episode of
puppy dog pals where the puppies were
playing a sort of football game I was
the voice of the announcer on that show
Richard yeah the character named Dan
which I'm sure Dan Patrick likes but you
know it's very yeah that was a bet
that's a big flex in my household man
they could care less about football when
it comes to puppy dog growls it's a big
big difference all right so let's get
into this preseason week number three
are you gonna be playing much Saturday
night what what do what is going on in
the preseason where it seems that not
many people have been playing as in
previous years well I mean it's just not
that you know it's not that important to
see your starters play when you
understand what you're going to get from
especially guys been playing for a
number of years you know with a number
of injuries that have happened in the
preseason I think teams are starting to
just play it more safe get more more
opportunities for their younger guys
that they want to evaluate and less
opportunities for the guys they will
they feel they have a pretty good
evaluation on but me on the other hand
I'll be playing I'll be playing some in
this game I think I'll be playing
between one and two quarters mostly was
the coach don't do okay and obviously a
lot of conversation is I'm sure you
might have picked up about Jimmy
garoppolo's performance in his first
preseason game back from the knee injury
what what can be gleaned into any of
that Richard I'm not much you know I
think Bradley Tobin and
Amber's front had a great plan and a
great next you didn't put a lot of
pressure in his face you know you're
coming off a knee and have a lot of
pressure in your face it's gonna be
uncomfortable throws and um it was just
unfortunate circumstances honestly I
don't think we were were concerned at
all he's had great practices he's
executed two offense beautifully
throughout the entire camp so you know
that's just kind of an aberration you
know operation of great deal on play
guys guys you know winning and getting
in his face really you know quickly and
I think any quarterback to have
difficult time to assess anything so you
know so you spent obviously Richard on
some championship teams and I use the
plural for a good reason to you know how
good can this team be this year uh we
can be we can be really good I think
defensively we've taken a lot of steps
forward just in terms of our consistency
our communication individuals just
understanding their role within the
defense and not not moving outside of
that I think for every Warner's taking a
huge step from his rookie year to a
second year just understanding defense
understanding his place in it um being
vocal I think Juan Alexander is gonna be
a great addition he's a great energy guy
and obviously both in d4 to bring us a
different and different mentality on the
outside rushing in and then you got Eric
and Sally and Depot and those guys all
make a vacuum we we've gotten better we
got a great competition at every spot
and I look forward to seeing what we put
out there playoff team you think your
playoff team yeah I would think we were
playoff team but you know saying it you
can say whatever you want and also and
then it's before the season you know
we've gotta go out there and execute it
so we'll see then Garoppolo again just
revisiting him what do you see in him
that makes you think my quarterbacks a
winner Richard just poise leadership his
accuracy the ability for him to take a
hit and keep keep stepping up and then
keep executing his responsibilities I
think that he's a guy that doesn't get
rattled you know just like this game I
think some quarterbacks thought that
cinnamon turn it's in their confidence
down drain he's got it takes an intro I
take responsibility for what happened
and continues to move forward
I look forward to him going out there
and executing and quieting all the
haters Richard Sherman 49ers cornerback
four-time Pro Bowler right here on the
Rich Eisen show let's talk about taking
responsibility you negotiated your own
contract and I saw on Twitter you were
congratulating Bobby Wagner for many
reasons one because he's fantastic as a
former teammate of yours and he also
negotiated his own contract why do you
think players don't do that as much
Richard well I just think it's part of
it's part of a systemic deal that's
always been going on it you know we love
doing things that has always been done
and and you know there's a bit of I'm
taking advantage of players that goes on
you know players that are uninformed or
uneducated coming out of college there's
a hint of desperation and those players
and guys just feeling like man I just
want to put in the door and these agents
taking advantage of that desperation and
giving them the foot in the door and
saying hey man I can get you on the team
I can get you drafted I can get you when
in reality if that player isn't going to
get drafted with an agent he's not going
to get drafted without an agent he's
gonna he's going to be able to to write
his own story either way you know if
you're under after free agent and you do
Co out in the training camp and execute
and and do a great job and you make it
53 that's but that isn't because your
agent got you there it's because you
were good enough player in the team so
fit for you to make 40 to 53 man roster
so I think it's just as players become
more educated throughout their careers I
think you'll see more players do it
I think that the contract language is
becoming more standardized you know
there's there's language that each team
tries to put in there and the PA is
aware of that and agents are aware of
that so I think you know at the end of
day high-priority players you know like
Bobby who's going to be the highest-paid
player at his position understand the
leverage that they have and and he used
it to his advantage to got the deal that
he wanted and in terms of the collective
bargaining agreement that's up in a
couple years I believe you are part of
the players that are involved in some of
these sessions is it possible something
can get done before the beginning of the
season you think Richard still to be
seen I think it's going to be difficult
I think there you know there's a lot of
progress that can be made before the
season starts but I think for us too
come to a tentative agreement and have
something signed and sealed and
delivered before September 8 this is
kind of a long shot you know just
because even if we have an agreement in
place and both sides agree we have to
show it to all our membership and have
to make sure everybody is on the same
page with everything and everybody
understands that in and they're okay
with the bill that comes across so
there's a lot of steps involved and to
do that during the season is difficult
so but who knows you know miracles
happen every day what is what is the
would you say the main issue here
for fans who are sitting here hearing no
conversations about franchise tags and
and player discipline and marijuana and
other subjects that constantly get
thrown at 18 games season extra playoff
teams what is actually that really is do
you think an on the table situation here
Richard well all those things on the
table um you know any time you're
building new stadiums that's that's on
the table just trying to figure out how
you get those funded and how to make
sure both sides benefit obviously the
splitting of the entire pie the revenue
is will always be a point of contention
for both sides I think that 18 games say
each seasons in terms of player safety
it's kind of a no starter for for the
players union for that for that reason
because you know you can't talk out of
both sides your mouths in that regard
and say you care about player safety
index that guys really need to be on the
forefront of player safety and then you
say you're putting players in to more
situations for them to endanger
themselves and so I think that's that's
them that the league in a PA are both
conscious of it and touched that moving
forward but I think that all those tapas
that she talked about commissioner just
to play on the field finds all those
have been talked about and debated hotly
in those meetings and will continue to
okay in terms of players safety there
isn't a subject that's happening and
a training camp up the road in Napa and
I know it's difficult to ask you Richard
Sherman a comment about other teams
players but it does appear to be a
player safety issue with Antonio Browns
helmet and the Players Association and
the NFL have agreed about red-flagged
helmets etc and so forth what do you
think about what is going on with
Antonio Brown and his helmet Richard
Sherman well I you know honestly I just
try to get him on my own business in
that regard you know I think it's a bit
of a bizarre situation you know as
players we do get stuck in our ways and
and we're creatures of habit and you
know man
he's worn a helmet since he was probably
in Pop Warner or a kid and put it and
tell him he can't wear it anymore it's
just one of those things that's
difficult a difficult pill for in the
swallow you know same with Tom Brady and
a-rod you know guys worn these helmets
for so long that it's difficult to say
man let's just change what's been
working for so long right now but I
think the league in the PA are doing the
best to make sure each player is safe
and each players is abiding by the rules
so I think it's a situation that that is
unique obviously it hasn't happened
before and I hope it gets resolved
quickly few more minutes left with
Richard Sherman 49ers cornerback here on
the Rich Eisen show what do you think of
pass interference both offense and
defense being reviewable for at least
one year what do you think of that
Richard well I you know I think they
just put often pass interference in
there just so it doesn't seem unfair but
I don't think that's a realistic just
like the penalty you know it's one one's
eyes can once I could be a fifty sixty
seventy five yard penalty the other so I
can only be a ten there are penalty and
repeat the same down I think that you
know there's obviously a slant in that
regard and I think the same thing will
be true for the way they review it you
know if you if you see a corner push off
and and intercept the ball I think
that's going to be decent to pass
interference every time and if you see a
receiver push off and catch a fade ball
they'll say oh well he didn't inhibit
the corner from making the play and it's
like well I don't see if the roles were
reversed and you would see it that way
but that's just the thing about playing
decent football initially you know they
want to see points they wanted all sense
to be successful and and they have
another tool to make
now Richard I just so you know I'll
river on the head of NFL refs and
speaking to the NFL media group and he
said the same thing to everybody but
that covers the NFL at every Network
showing a video of last year's Thursday
Night Football game where the Chargers
got a defensive pass interference call
to their benefit on the Chiefs ball said
at the one-yard line that if that
happens this year they would go under
the review process and because in the
last two minutes and they would have
they would have called it back not
because it wasn't defensive pass
interference but it would have been an
offsetting penalty they would have
called offensive pass interference on a
push off at the same time they would
have done that that's what he they swear
to me that Olli is going to be in
crucial it it's always funny how how
retro actively they say they would have
done something and then the situation
will cause themself this year and they
won't they won't do that because that's
not that's not how this game works this
is offensive game they want the ball if
you have to want they wanted to they
want it to be a chance for the offense
to score points so I mean it's easy to
say in hindsight man that would agree to
call that both ways you know but in the
heat of the battle when when the
pressure is on they're gonna call it off
inside of they always have okay so you
just you you're basically saying that
the defense is second it's just the
second thought by the NFL I mean we're
all right well and before before I let
you go what what what does it mean to be
entering the season in season nine I
mean do you that you've been there
you've done that you've played in Super
Bowls you're now it's trying to start
something again what what what what do
you what goes through your temples is
you're getting set to to play this game
for yet another season Richard man joy
joy I enjoy doing this it's this really
fun game out I enjoy being out there I
enjoy every part of football the
adversity the trials tribulations the
intensity the physicality and you know a
year nine I'm still enjoying it as much
you're one that's that's why I keep
playing you know I hope this continues I
hope that I continue to get a chance to
play this great game and but I'm having
fun and I hope we were able to do
something special this year and happy to
be a part of it and does it mean
something when you go into Seattle do
you circle the game you do that
I don't circle I don't circle any games
I've learned that a long time ago you
treat treat every game the same but but
it's always fun to go back there and and
and to play hard you play under a crowd
you know last year we got to win and
hopefully this year we can we could do
it again
yeah and you know what I mean you're
gonna end up seeing you're gonna go
visit it seems Earl Thomas and his new
digs later on yeah we get there we get
the Earl in Baltimore so there will be a
lot of fun yeah and he confirmed that he
was telling the coach that he was number
one last year as he got carted off
Richard did you hear that right that's
what he told me you know behind closed
doors - it was obvious I thought you
take care of yourself thanks for the
call okay and I'd love to chat with you
during the season - so look for my call
then - okay I will
I'll look for you the man that's Richard
Sherman I follow on - on Twitter you
should as well are Sherman underscore 25
and without the underscore on Instagram
right here in the Rich Eisen show for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app